اداؤها يشبه البشر شات جي بي تي تتحدى من
جديد وتطلق نسخه جديده من تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي التي تعمل على تشغيل روبوت
الدردشه الشهير هي جي بي تي 4 النسخه
الجديده وستكون نموذجا رائعا تقول الشركه
للوسائط المتعدده اقل مهاره من البشر في
عديد من سيناريوهات الحياه الواقعيه
ولكنها جيده مثل البشر في اداء العديد من
المهام المهنيه والاكاديميه على سبيل
المثال يمكنها اجتياز الامتحان ليصبح
محاميا بدرجه ممتازه تتجاوز نجاح المحامين
البشر بعشره بالمئه في حين كانت النسخه
السابقه وهي جيبي جي بي تي ثري بوينت فايف
في مستوى ادنى وعلى عكس الاصدارات السابقه
يمكن للنسخه الجديده معالجه النص والصور
كذلك ومع ذلك فانها حاليا
تولد النصوص فقط وستكون متاحه على تشات جي
بي تي لكن من دون امكانيه تزويدها بالصور
في الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]